how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in double so what would you say if
we had a gathering if you were
addressing a gathering of Isis
supporters here who believed that they
were acting in accordance with the Word
of God and they had profoundly different
views than you did about certain
behaviors would you just say you've just
got the moral facts wrong guys you
haven't seen how it is really are you
asking what I would think of what I
would say of course I would not say that
that would be a completely stupid thing
to say you know when you're having a
moral disagreement with somebody I mean
and this this actually brings out
something really important which is that
sometimes we think morality is about
this shared understanding of the
humanity of each other and how that
motivates us to care about each other
and transcend our selfish interests but
other aspects of morality are taken to
be about honor or pollution or my
country matters more than anything else
and it's a real question whether that
actually belongs to morality so one
serious worry is the harnessing of the
rhetoric of morality to stuff that is
not actually morality at all
that's what I think is going on with
certain moral views including those of
Isis which you mentioned but what I say
that of course not that's not a good way
to get a conversation going you start
from what you have in common and work
from there get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in aaaggghhh